testing audio
testing audio
testing audio one two three four
we're good
ladies and gentlemen it'll be the same
setup as in the previous days i'll uh
i'll bring the mic around for you to
ask your questions when joe gets out
here should be just should just be a few
minutes
thank you
uh
good morning everyone the report for
today staff is doing an excellent job of
moving through those ballots and today
we're very confident that we will have
all of those read into the system that
we've been discussing day after day
after day
yesterday we ended up getting about
twenty three thousand ballots through
the system
and today we have a balance of little
over sixteen thousand
so that is the bulk of the mail ballots
that have come through
but again i remind the public
that there are still outstanding ballots
in different areas the provisionals are
being worked on
uh the same day registration updates is
the first group which is the largest
that's 27 thousand
staff is nearly complete running through
those
to do the confirmation and now we're
moving to the in person and online
and also the hava provisionals we've got
a large group of staff next door going
through and verifying that so that
when we send the report to the secretary
and it comes back we'll be prepared to
roll those ballots into the system
i have been informed by the secretary of
state that they'll be expecting
our voter list as those people who have
voted for early voting
election day and the mail up to them on
monday
so on monday once they get that they'll
be able to take the records from all 16
other counties in nevada and begin to
prepare the report that we need to see
so that we'll have the ability to get
those ballots counted and into the
system
hopefully by sometime on wednesday
we're still working on cures obviously
this is those group of ballots that
would be outside of the numbers that i'm
reporting
we'll continue to put two reports out
on a daily basis this afternoon there'll
be another report
no mail today sunday's not a postage day
and the staff will be working to
continue helping voters at the
702-455-6552 line
for so anybody that needs to cure their
ballot and that
that deadline will be this thursday the
12th
and with that i'll take any questions
that you might have this morning
thank you again for doing this mr gloria
um the nevada gop
has come out with more allegations now
alleging that
certain ballots are not having
signatures verified
here in this office and are also
alleging that some ballots are being
predated
i was wondering if you could just
respond to those allegations from what
you're seeing
just to clarify what you said did you
say predated
yes sir i'm not certain what that means
but i can tell you that every ballot
that comes through
this office does have the signature
check
as a result of ab4 it's important that
the general public understand that
we have a cure process now that's
defined in the law
and so there's no course for me to go
outside
of that cure responsibility if somebody
cures their ballot
we are obligated to count that ballot so
i don't have all the details on exactly
what the claims are but
i'm sure that we have a good explanation
for anything that they've put forth
just to clarify predating the accusation
is is that ballots
were postmarked after election day and
then manipulated to change
the dates just clarifying that that
that's simply untrue uh the system is is
being checked
um and it's only the mail that's coming
in there were 25 yesterday
uh there was more than 25 but those were
rejected that didn't have the postmark
so
we're following the law on every step
that we're supposed to do here in this
office
the mail that came in also on wednesday
went through the same process we have to
go through and verify that it's
postmarked november third
so that work is being done and we're
doing it accurately
next question hi this is um
a bit related one of the specific
allegations
is in the form of a signed affidavit
from somebody who
said that they were working here
processing ballots
and said that there were some signatures
that this person thought were not
matching
the envelope but was told to push them
through anyway and
one instance of somebody who
on the i i assume the envelope said that
they did not live here and he was told
to he or she i don't know was told to
push that ballot through
as well do you know anything about that
how
would those concerns be handled by
somebody
who's working here who came up with
these
problems okay those are two situations
that can be very clearly explained
sometimes voters will put on the
envelope that they've moved
but they're still submitting their
ballot to be counted there are several
residents here in clark county that live
in the area could have gone for school
could have gone anywhere
and they indicate on the ballot that
their co their change of address so they
need to get with us to get that change
of address but they were still eligible
to vote in this county
so those ballots were processed to be
counted i believe you said something
about the signature
match the the people on uh the counting
board don't have access to the signature
match
so that's work that takes place here in
this building before it ever gets to the
counting board
um so i i think that
explains i i'm not completely familiar
with what exactly the individual is
talking about in specific instances but
i believe we have an explanation for
anything uh that he may have seen
next question
good morning i have a question here i've
been
hearing a few cases that the voters
told us that they register early they
vote early on the first day the voter
register opened
and yes on the friday when they checked
their status
and they found out they are become a
provisional
voter and they asking for their
officer i mean the worker there what's
the reason
to listing them as a professional voter
they can't really tell so you mentioned
about early yesterday
i'm sorry you said that they contacted
my office and my staff said
they couldn't tell them they went to the
office and they talked to the
people working in that office go ahead
and finish your question i apologize
yeah
so um which means like they are they
just told them
your balance still in processing so
that's correct
yeah so they want to what they just want
to know like
how could be they register early and
they vote early
and only in person they become a
professional matter is it you
her anything that your worker reported
to you your system
having any problem to least early
register voter become a provisional
holder
all same day voters are provisional
ballots
that's the simple answer um their ballot
will get counted once we verify that
they have not voted in another county
so this report that i've been talking
about for several days
uh related to the secretary of state
again i have to explain that
we on similar to colorado colorado has a
top-down voter registration system
which means that all of the counties in
colorado bounce back and forth to one
database
that's not the case in nevada we're a
bottom up voter registration
so all of us have to send all reports to
the secretary so that they can merge
data and make sure that
everything's being processed without
anybody
voting illegal ballots so every single
same-day registration that came through
in person whether it was early voting or
election day are provisional ballots
every single one of them so those are in
process
when i started today i explained those
60 000 provisional ballots are being
processed right now we're going through
to make sure that we've got the
documentation to confirm that those
voters are eligible to vote
we'll send that report to the secretary
on monday on wednesday when we begin to
roll those ballots in that should be
counted
then we'll have an indication that that
ballot has counted and for all voters
it's important to know
vote history is not posted until after
the election
which is correct oh sorry they
are not saying the register registered
voter they are already registered they
register on september 21st
and that is what the system told them
they came to here they check it
and they showing on the system they
register on september 21st
they voted on october 17th and they be
still become a provisional
voter and again when you come in if you
make an update to your registration
that's still a same-day registration
i would have to know exactly who this
voter is so that i can look them up in
the system but i'll be happy to look
into it
to get the answer to that but if they
voted provisionally that means that
either they did an update they voted or
registered in person
or they registered online so those would
all be
provisional ballots but they will be
counted once we confirm that they're
eligible
next question hey joe joe bartels 13
action is here in las vegas um
in the same vein it sounds like there's
a pattern here we asked you yesterday
about any number of reports or issues
you had nefarious or
illegitimate ballots do you have a
specific number of reports you have
received at this point now
no i do not
hey joe john trainer of ksnb here uh two
questions for you one you talked about
this a little bit what is the the
schedule for
um the next update i believe you said
this afternoon and when do you plan on
getting the initial batch the account
today
up to the secretary of state the
the the information on provisionals
which is what i was discussing
uh they've given us instructions to send
that tomorrow
okay so there'll be an email coming from
the secretary's office and their staff
giving us the instructions on how to get
that up to them and
and once they have all 17 counties
they'll begin the work so we're hoping
that by wednesday
we'll be prepared to start the automated
process of
putting those ballots in that should be
counted into the system
um i know this is unbelievable because
the numbers haven't even been released
yet but there's already talk in
in georgia and pennsylvania and other
states that have been close about
recounts does your office automatically
prepare for that what's the process
here before a recount is called for to
just get ready for one in case there is
one
candidates have the ability to request a
recount after the election
we are preparing for that we are
prepared to do the recount um
the law has changed in the state of
nevada a little bit on exactly how we
reimburse for those costs so candidates
will need to
pay up front for the cost for us to
recount but we're prepared to do so
depends on the race
next question
hi um so i know the viewers had said
that the number of ballots that have
come in
after election day is relatively
small um do you have figures
i know you said all of those with
postmarks that are after election day
won't be counted do you have a figure on
how many those are
and you have figure on how many where
the post mark
couldn't be determined because it was
smudged or some instance
like that no i'm sorry we don't have
that information yet we're completely
focused on getting the good ballots
counted so
after the election we would certainly
certainly be able to give
information along those lines but we're
completely focused on getting through
the provisionals the cures
the rest of our mail ballots so that we
can uh begin the work of
reconciling everything
mr gloria as you mentioned yesterday you
all just became a male in ballot county
this year this is all new territory for
you and your staff so
looking at this from a 20 000 foot view
is there anything that you all have
identified that you think needs to be
redressed going forward and how well do
you think that your staff has been able
to
handle all this juggling you've had to
do in all these changes over the last
couple of months
that's a good question uh let me start
off by clarifying and saying mail
ballots are not brand new to us
mail ballots have been available through
absentee for many years in nevada and
our processes are basically the same
the quantity of ballots that we received
this year as a result of going all mail
due to the pandemic that's what changed
our whole operation substantially
because we're used in clark county
to supporting a huge in-person early
voting election day turnout
voters in clark county have clearly
indicated to us
that they liked that process but due to
the pandemic we had to
put the mail ballot in i i if you're
asking for my opinion on on how we've
done it's a little early
for me to say but i can tell you that uh
my staff
worked tirelessly to develop
the process that we would need how we
would adjust what additional employees
would be needed what additional
equipment
all the way down to we had to create
safe working environments for all these
folks who have to do this manual work
that we're talking about on the
signature check
on the counting board disinfectant
plexiglas screens separating the workers
there was just
a massive amount of logistical uh things
that we had to do i think they've done
an excellent job i steer this ship
but i've got an amazing group of
individuals who are working over their
long hours dealing with
everything that's going on around this
building i can't say enough about my
staff
we never would have made it through this
without a dedicated group of people who
work here permanently
the temporary people who have come in
through agencies the poll workers
it i mean it's overwhelming when i stop
and think about
what they've done and i'm very proud of
them
mr gloria orco mano with channel 8. uh
can you describe how the ballot curing
process has been going have there been
any instances of certain ballots just
being really difficult
to kind of you know get that information
from or how is the
curing process going right now the
statute is very clear
on exactly what we need to do we
initially contact these voters to let
them know that they haven't signed their
ballot or their signature didn't match
but after that it's up to the voter to
get back to us
on our hotline but the information that
they need to provide is very simple
it's an affidavit and a copy of the
nevada id or they can answer challenge
questions to get that ballot cured once
they've done so
we it's our mandate to count those
ballots uh it's gone
very smooth um
that group has been working on a hotline
i think it's at least a couple of weeks
now
that they've been processing we're down
to less than
two thousand i think of open cures so i
think the process has worked well
have a great day thank you all for being
here